les Jeux olympiques du 26 juillet au 11
août et je parle un pic maintenant du 28
août au 8 septembre c'est dans l'agenda
en 2024 la France va accueillir un
événement historique on est Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques vous pouvez
le constater je suis dans les Start and
blocks et je ne suis pas le seul la 7e
édition de la Semaine Olympique et
paralympique vient de se terminer
l'objectif de cet événement promouvoir
la pratique sportive et ses valeurs en
milieu éducatif de la maternelle à
l'université c'est très important vous
allez le voir de pratiquer une activité
physique que vous ayez des
prédispositions ou pas pour la santé
bien sûr mais pas que c'est aussi un
excellent moyen de créer du lien social
de lutter contre les discriminations et
de favoriser l'inclusion je vous emmène
aujourd'hui à la rencontre de Para
athlètes exceptionnel Sofiane meyaoui
qui pratique le basket fauteuil en
équipe de France et maintenant Keita
championnat olympique de 400 mètres et
puis j'ai également invité Michel Cymes
qui viendra nous parler de sport et de
santé
ça va être musclé
[Musique]
Sofiane m'a donné rendez-vous au gymnase
de Gennevilliers en attendant de
représenter la France aux Jeux
paralympiques de 2024 c'est ici qu'il
s'entraîne avec ses coéquipiers du club
le weekend 92
[Musique]
c'est physique dis-moi vous vous
entraînez souvent comme ça assez souvent
parce que on essaie de travailler en
même temps le cardio et en même temps de
se mettre en situation de match et tout
ça c'est dans la prévision des JO on
prépare les jeux par la pièce de 2024 et
pour ça on a avant tout le Championnat
du Monde au mois de juin championnat
d'Europe au mois d'août et un tournoi
qualificatif au mois de septembre ça
fait un programme très très chargé c'est
assez drôle parce que moi j'ai pratiqué
le basket quand j'étais jeune grosso
modo jusqu'à l'âge de 20 ans je te la
louche j'étais pas très très bon mais
c'est un sport que que j'adore
d'ailleurs quand j'ai commencé mon
métier de journaliste je commentais des
matchs de de basket estima le plus
marqué la première fois que j'ai assisté
à un match de basket fauteuil c'est la
dimension du terrain exactement le même
terrain que celui sur lequel je jouais
le terrain c'est exactement les mêmes
les distances à trois points sont
exactement les mêmes la hauteur des
paniers est aussi pareil 3 mètres 0,5
donc exactement pareil je commence
l'entraînement aujourd'hui moi
exactement on y va
tout le monde peut jouer on soit
handicapé phosphore aussi valide et
c'est un sport qui est mixte parce que
les filles les garçons peuvent jouer par
contre personne valide juste en
championnat de France mais pas au jeu
paralympiques par exemple ou en tournant
international et comment ce parasport le
basket hauteuil ça a permis de mieux
vivre de bien vivre ton handicap ce
sport le basket fauteuil m'a permis de
me dépasser de montrer aux autres de
quoi je suis capable de faire ça m'a
permis vraiment de montrer démontrer que
je suis un sportif et je peux faire des
choses par moi-même tu t'es dépassé mais
est-ce que c'est aussi un facteur
d'inclusion oui aussi parce que entre
nous le fait que ça soit un sport court
on n'est pas tendre on fait pas de
cadeau à l'autre donc tout de suite
quand on retourne dans la vie dans la
vie classique on est un peu sans
protéger je suis une personne en
situation handicap donc du coup on veut
pas forcément faire de mal ou quand on
est dans la dans l'association justement
on est entre nous donc on peut se moquer
de nous on n'a pas de difficultés
si on tombe de son fauteuil on rigole de
la situation et ce qui est normal et il
y a plus de barrière on voit plus le
handicap est-ce que l'arrivée de des
Jeux paralympiques à ton avis a changé
le regard du public sur sur le handicap
sur les personnes en situation de
handicap oui bien sûr parce qu'on en
parle de plus en plus on essaye aussi de
comprendre le dépassement le sport et
pas essayer de juste comprendre le
handicap merci merci pour tout
on l'a vu avec Sofiane meyaoui pratiquer
une activité sportive quand on est en
situation de handicap c'est possible et
ça fait du bien les Jeux paralympiques
sont une compétition sportive qui se
déroule juste après les Jeux Olympiques
et à laquelle participent des personnes
en situation de handicap de manière tout
à fait logique les athlètes
paralympiques pratiques des passeports
il y a le paradis d'eau le tennis
fauteuil le Cécifoot ou encore le
volley-ball assis il existe aujourd'hui
en France une multitude de parasports
collectifs ou individuels rien qu'au jeu
paralympiques de 2024 pas moins de 23
disciplines seront représentées
aujourd'hui toutes les personnes en
situation de handicap quel qu'il soit
peuvent donc trouver l'activité physique
correspondant à leur profil et à leur
motivation
j'ai rendez-vous avec maintenat Keita
c'est l'une des parallètes les plus
talentes de sa génération elle a été
championne du monde sur 400 mètres en
2015 plusieurs fois médaillées aux Jeux
paralympiques en 2008 à Pékin en 2012 à
Londres et en 2016 à Rio je vais aller
la rejoindre pendant une pause parce que
sur la piste elle va un peu trop vite
pour moi
[Musique]
bonjour d'Antonin alors toi ta
discipline c'est le para-atlétisme plus
précisément le 400 mètres et alors quand
on te voit les ans avec laquelle tu te
déplaces sur la piste c'est très
impressionnant on a on a même du mal à
imaginer que tu es malvoyante alors moi
j'ai un handicap visuel un handicap de
naissance parce que je suis albinos et
quand on est albinos dans 99% des cas il
y a une déficience visuelle qui est
accompagnée j'ai un champ de un champ
visuel qui est réduit parce qu'en fait
j'ai beaucoup plus de facilité à voir
sur le côté que de voir en face tu
t'entraînes régulièrement on est sportif
de haut niveau donc on a les mêmes
exigences que tout sportif de haut
niveau sont les mêmes peut-être qu'on
peut aller s'entraîner ensemble
tu vas me servir de coach ouais
[Musique]
ça va nanthana ça va c'est quoi ton
meilleur temps 400 mètres
et comment se passe justement tu as
permis de bien vivre c'est handicap le
sport et notamment le paralympique ça
m'a vraiment permis de prendre
conscience que mon handicap et ben
c'était pas une fin en soi dont on
inquiétait c'est pas qu'une personne
déficiente visuelle c'est pas qu'une
sportive de haut niveau c'est les deux
en fait et à un moment donné dans ma vie
je me disais que si j'étais en situation
de handicap si j'étais albino si j'étais
déficiente visuelle et ben forcément ma
vie elle serait pas bien que je serai
pas heureuse dans ma vie parce que les
gens me définissaient seulement de par
cette apparence physique là et en fait
le sport m'a permis de me définir
autrement et notamment le sport parle
olympique nous on a déjà passé un très
très bon moment en ta compagnie
que l'on soit ou non en situation de
handicap faire du sport ou pratiquer une
activité physique nous aide à dépasser
nos limites tout en développant nos
capacités physiques et mentales alors
cette idée n'est pas nouvelle déjà au
premier siècle avant Jésus-Christ le
poète romain Juvénal en faisait le
constat c'est lui qui est à l'origine de
cette petite phrase que tout le monde
connaît un esprit saint dans un corps
sain et pour parler de ce sujet j'ai
invité un ami un expert qui va nous
expliquer pourquoi faire du sport ou
pratiquer une activité physique c'est
important pour la tête pour le reste du
corps salut Michel ça va alors cher
Michel tu es médecin ça tout le monde le
sait tu fais également pas mal de sport
et tu es aussi ambassadeur santé de
Paris 2024 pourquoi est-il si important
de faire du sport pour la santé physique
et mentale aussi les recommandations
sont très précises elles ont été données
par l'Organisation mondiale de la santé
de ceux qu'on parle souvent de 10000 pas
par jour on oublie ça surtout il faut
retenir 30 minutes d'activité physique
quotidienne pour les adultes 30 minutes
pour les adultes on recommande le double
pour les enfants les plus jeunes
pourquoi tout ce temps chez un chez un
enfant parce que c'est indispensable et
qu'on est dans une situation
catastrophique en France sur le plan de
l'activité physique chez les jeunes
l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé a
fait un classement sur un peu près 145
pays dans le monde sur le niveau
d'activité physique des jeunes des
jeunes enfants adolescents on est la
France 119e donc il y a un vrai problème
en France il faut que nos jeunes bougent
les raisons pour lesquelles ils bougent
pas on les connaît les écrans en
attendant ça va être un peu flemmard
quand on est gamin et c'est
indispensable parce que c'est en
bougeant qu'on fait bouger non seulement
les muscles mais que on aide la
croissance et la densité osseuse et puis
pour le moral c'est aussi très très bon
des bienfaits que l'on retrouve
également chez les adultes et on dit
aussi que les personnes qui sont en
situation de handicap doivent pratiquer
une activité physique il y a des
adaptations en fonction du type de
handicap mais ces personnes doivent
impéra tivement bouger également
ou ça m'a mis en forme ce petit tennis
avec Michel je vais poursuivre
l'entraînement à l'école j'ai
rendez-vous avec les élèves d'une classe
de CE2 de Clamart l'école Charles de
Gaulle
[Musique]
bonjour les enfants
bonjour Florine on va apprendre à
jongler puis après à jongler avec une
mobilité réduite
merci beaucoup
vainqueur
bravo
[Applaudissements]
une épreuve cette fois-ci de football
puis après de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà j'espère que cette immersion dans
l'espoir paralympiques vous a plu comme
vous avez pu constater les paraports
favorisent l'inclusion on peut tous les
pratiquer que l'on soit en situation de
handicap ou non et je suis convaincu que
maintenant après cette découverte et
bien vous serez nombreux à venir
soutenir à mes côtés les athlètes lors
des Jeux paralympiques de 2024 à Paris
allez à très bientôt en petite foulée
[Applaudissements]